اكد حاكم ولايه فلوريدا ران ديسانتوس
تقديمه اوراقه
للترشح رسميا للانتخابات الرئاسيه
الامريكيه عن الحزب الجمهوري ويعتبر
المنافس الابرز لدونالد ترامب لكسب ترشيح
الحزب الجمهوريه كما سينافس الفائز في
الانتخابات التمهيديه للحزب الجمهوريه
المرشح الذي يختاره الحزب الديمقراطي
الكثير من المحافظين على ديسانتوس البالغ
اربعه واربعين عاما خصوصا بعد اعاده
انتخابه حاكما لفلوريدا في نوفمبر الماضي
باغلبيه مريحه
ومعنا الان من واشنطن مراسلنا ناصر
الحسيني اهل الناصر يعني واضح الان ان
الامور اصبحت اكثر يعني رسميه المنافسه
المحتدمه هذه بين
ترامب الان بعد الاعلان رسميا ما الذي
يمكن ان نتوقعه
هذا الاعلان تمر سنين وقبل قليل فقط اعلن
ايضا في الشريط فيديو ايضا انه سيترشح
ويقدم اوراقه اذا ليكون المرشح ليسعى الان
لتزكيه من الحزب الجمهوري
لمنصب رئيس الولايات المتحده لكنه سيخوض
كما تعلمين ليله معركه طاحنه مع تراب
وشخصيه ترامب رئيس ترامب حتى الان تمكن من
وضعه في الزاويه كما نقول عبر حملات جد
مسعوره استبقت هذا الاعلان ضد ويرى فيه
ذلك الشاب الذي يخيفه بطبيعه الحال حاله
مستقبله السياسي لنادي سانتيس بالفعل له
تلك الشخصيه القويه اثبت على الاقل في
ولايه فلوريدا انه مدير
للشؤون الاقتصاديه بشكل ناجح اثناء كوفيد
ولايه فلوريدا لم تتضرر كثيرا طبيعه الحال
له مواقفه المحافظه التي يتفق معها او لا
يتفق معها الامريكيون كثيرا لكن على مستوى
ولايه فلوريدا له الشعب قويه والاهم من
هذا له ايضا كثير من المتعاطفين المستعدين
لدفع الاموال وراءه الكثير من المال هذا
بطبيعه الحال يخيف الرئيس ترامب لكن حتى
اللحظه ونحن نتحدث كل استطاعات الراي
مازلت تعطي الرئيس ترامب وشخصيته داخل
الحزب جمهوري الاولويه والاسبقيه اكثر من
خمسين بالمئه من القاعده الحزبيه لهذا
الحزب الجمهوري التي ستصوت بعد اشهر من
سيكون مرشحه لمنصب الرئاسه معظمها في هذه
اللحظه في هذه الاثناء
تميل الى الرئيس ترامب لكن من يدري
ديسانتس 44 عاما عكس رئيس ترامب له كافه
طاقه الشاب المتعلم الذي يسعى الان
للرئاسه وسيكون بالفعل امتحانا صعبا امام
الشخصيه مثل رئيس ترامب سنتابع